votre mère il faut la comprendre et les
mariés un homme qui n'est pas votre père
est là bien sûr construit sa vie sans
vous je suis désolée elle ne souhaite
pas vraiment compris
j'aimerais également faire mieux
boule à facettes
ne touchez à rien ce qui compte
désormais c'est les disputes in quête
rues des villes armes la fête oui oui
servir les invités par dans à l'asie il
apporta une coupe de champagne à la main
building vous savez où aller
face à ce niveau pardon je suis désolé
faut que j'attende entre chaque hoquet
pour pouvoir parler
j'étais à goûter et ligotent ni mon ami
à lui parler françois situe lui explique
ce que tu ressens et écoutera c'est
comme en format de parler
bah non
enfin si si si si ça va très bien
pourquoi il ya des pirogues et omar dans
la maison c'est toi qui leur were n'a
pas la première elle a vu s'il vous
plaît occupez vous du barbecue parce
qu'il ya de la fumée light
mais peut pas plus tant que moment donné
je me suis dit que tu allais
certainement pouvoir bizarrement
débarrasser